>> Laura: THE BIG QUESTION
NOW FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THE COUNTRY IS WHETHER THE
END ROBERT MUELLER WANTS
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
LET'S ASK FORMER FBI
SPOKESPERSON JOHN IN
AN ATTORNEY WHO SERVED IN
BOTH THE REAGAN AND BUSH 41
ADMINISTRATIONS.
DAVID, I WANTED TO START
WITH YOU, SHOULD THIS
MUELLER INVESTIGATION BE
ENDED WITH WHAT YOU KNOW
IF FURTHER INVESTIGATION
REVEALS THERE IS ADDITIONAL
MISCONDUCT THAT LED TO THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: THIS MEMO SAYS
ESSENTIAL ELEMENT IN THOSE
WARRANTS BEING THE DOSSIER.
THEY ADMITTED A MATERIAL
FACT TO THE FISA JUDGE,
TRUMP'S OPPONENT.
>> WHICH THEY DID NOT TELL
THE FISA COURT.
>> Laura: I'M CURIOUS WHY
YOU SAY THIS IS ONE IF THEY
FIND OUT MORE.
I GUESS THERE COULD BE MORE.
ISN'T THAT ENOUGH?
IF YOU ARE ESSENTIALLY LYING
TO A FEDERAL JUDGE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN, TWO WEEKS BEFORE
AN ELECTION, DOESN'T THAT
SHOW A MOTIVATION THAT'S NOT
EXACTLY PURE AS THE DRIVEN
SNOW.
>> NO, OF COURSE VERY
TROUBLING TO INVESTIGATORS.
>> Laura: TROUBLING?
>> MUELLER HIMSELF OR HIS
STAFF ARE NOT DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN THIS.
I WOULD RATHER FOCUS ON
WHAT.
>> Laura: YEAH, BUT IT WAS
STARTED, DAVID.
>> I UNDERSTAND THE FRUIT OF
THE POISONOUS TREE.
BUT LOOK, EVEN EVEN IF THERE
IS NO MUELLER INVESTIGATION
WHAT HAPPENED HERE IS
ENORMOUSLY TROUBLING.
IT'S A SERIOUS MISCONDUCT BY
THE FBI AND DOJ.
I WOULD RATHER FOCUS ON THE
MERITS OF A CASE.
VERSUS TALKING ABOUT AT THIS
STAGE WHAT ITS IMOCCASIONS IMPLI
STAGE WHAT ITS IMOCCASIONS IMPLA
STAGE WHAT ITS IMOCCASIONS IMPLN
STAGE WHAT ITS IMOCCASIONS IMPLS
ARE.
>> Laura: JOHN, I THINK THE
FBI TODAY, IF I WERE A
VETERAN OF THE FBI, I
WOULDN'T BE MAD AT THE TRUMP
TO BE POLITICIZED AND,
AGAINST THIS CANDIDATE TRUMP
AND THEN AFTER THE ELECTION
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I THINK THE FBI AGENTS WERE
USED AND THE YOU WERE
ERROR AT THE VERY LEAST.
OUTSIDE THE FBI THAT FEEL
EXACTLY THE SAME WAY.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, THERE IS
NO REASON AN INVESTIGATION
OF THIS MAGNITUDE SHOULD BE
RUN OUT OF FBI HEADQUARTERS.
THE WASHINGTON FIELD OFFICE
HAS A THOUSAND AGENTS.
TEAMS OF PEOPLE THAT DO THIS
SORT OF THING THIS IS A
PROBLEM OF MANAGEMENT TO
HAVE LET THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WRAY NEEDS TO
ADDRESS AND ADDRESS
IMMEDIATELY.
>> Laura: I STILL AM TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHY DIRECTOR
RAY WRAY WAS SAYING THERE
WAS A GRAVE CONCERN ABOUT
RELEASING THE MEMO.
THERE ARE NO SOURCES, NO
METHODS, NO COMPROMISE
FOREIGN AGENT NAMES.
NONE OF THAT WHY WERE THEY
BUTTING OUT, INCLUDING WRAY,
WHY WERE THEY PUTTING OUT
THESE FALSE JUSTIFICATION
FORCE KEEPING THAT MEMO
SECRET?
THAT, TO ME, IS VERY
CONCERNING.
AND I HAVE NO REASON TO NOT
LIKE CHRISTOPHER WRAY.
I'M SURE IS HE A WONDERFUL
PERSON.
WHY ARE YOU SAYING IT'S
GOING TO BE GRAVE?
GRAVE DAMAGE?
PEOPLE DOING THE GRAVE
DAMAGE TO THE FBI OR THE FBI
LEADERSHIP.
DAVID?
>> IT LOOKS BAD FOR THE FBI.
IT'S PURE SELF-PROTECTION.
WHICH DOVETAILS WITH THE
THREAT OF CONTEMPT.
>> Laura: EXPLAIN WHAT YOU
ARE SAYING.
>> IT TOOK A YEAR FOR THE
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES TO
GET THIS INFORMATION.
>> Laura: FROM THE FBI.
LIKE PULLING TEETH.
>> PULLING TEETH.
NOTHING TO DO WITH
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IT
HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT THIS
IS A SERIOUS MISCONDUCT THAT
MAKES THE FBI LOOK BAD.
>> Laura: THAT SHOULD
HAPPEN?
>> SERIOUS INVESTIGATION.
LET ME FLAG ONE THING.
IT'S NOT JUST WHAT WAS IN
THIS MANY OCCASION.
>> Laura: OCTOBER 21st.
>> RIGHT.
WHY NOT DO IT MONTHS
EARLIER?
WHY NOT DO IT AFTER
ELECTIONS?
BY ERIC HOLDER THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHICH SAYS YOU DON'T
INVESTIGATE ABSENT
OF THE DANGER IT WOULD LEAK
AND INTERFERE WITH THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS.
>> Laura: WHY DID HE WRITE
THAT MEMO WAS THAT BECAUSE
OF THE BENGHAZI STUFF.
>> LET'S ASSUME HE WROTE IT
YES, DURING THE 2012
ELECTIONS.
SO THE REAL QUESTION IS NOT
WHY DID YOU DO IT ON
OCTOBER 21, 2016, TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE ELECTIONS?
WHAT WAS THE URGENCY?
>> Laura: JOHN, WHAT HAPPENS
TO THE LEADERSHIP OF THE FBI
NOW, GIVEN WHAT WE LEARNED
TODAY IN THIS MEMO AND WE'RE
HEARING THAT THERE IS MORE
TO COME.
THIS IS JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG AS TO WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO LEARN AND I CAN'T
WAIT TO SEE WHETHER A IT IS.
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN, JOHN?
>> WELL, I SEE IT HAPPENING
ALREADY WITH THE DIRECTOR
WRAY.
THERE'S MOVEMENTS BEING
MADE.
SOMEWHAT GLASURELY CHANGES
ARE HAPPENING AT THE
HEADQUARTERS.
YOU SAW MCCABE LEAVE JUST
EARLIER THIS WEEK AND IN HIS
PLACE IS DEPUTY DIRECTOR
VERY HIGHLY REGARDED
THROUGHOUT THE RANK AND FILE
OF THE FBI.
YOU ARE ALSO STARTING TO SEE
OTHER MOVEMENTS WITH
EXECUTIVE LEADERS IN THE
FBI.
I THINK THE FIRST THING
DIRECTOR WRAY NEEDS TO DO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE WIPED
THE SLATE CLEAN OF THESE
DOING WHAT GOOD FBI AGENTS
ARE CHARGED WITH DOING.
>> Laura: DAVID, ALMOST OUT
OF TIME.
BUT COMEY'S CHIEF OF STAFF,
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF ON TV
JUDGE AND TOLD THEM ABOUT
FUNDED IT THERE WERE THINGS